under proper
and agenda item one is apologies for
absence and apologies have been received
from councillor john mason councillor
bob milne and councillor david sharp
substitute members
councillor hoy is substituting for
councillor mason
councillor foster is substituting for
councillor milne and councillor cross is
substituting for councillor sharp
agenda item three non-members attending
um councillor mrs wilson
uh councillor belton is uh councillor
mrs belton rather is attending for item
six as the portfolio holder
and councillor f day and williams are
attending for item nine of the agenda as
portfolio holders
also in attendance we have councillor
wootton councillor mrs rowe
and councillor wald
so welcome all of you to the meeting
thank you
agenda item for members is the minutes
of the meeting held on the 5th of april
2022
are the minutes agreed members
okay thank you those minutes are agreed
agenda item five is to uh receive
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
okay thank you none indicating thank you
move on to agenda item six which is the
economic growth strategy
before i introduce the
assistant director for place and
environment to introduce the report i'll
just remind you of the procedure for if
we make recommendations so what will
happen is if as a result of our
discussions we make recommendations
i'll ask you to
state the recommendation and then what
we'll do is the officers will then type
those up we'll take a short break and
then we'll come back into the room and
those recommendations will be shown on
the screen for everyone to vote on okay
so
i would like to invite marcus hotton the
assistant director for place environment
to introduce the report please
good evening members
um
the uh economic growth strategy before
you uh this evening
uh sets out the uh key themes
uh priorities and objectives uh that the
council aspires to deliver
uh it replaces the last such strategy
from 2017
and is based on three main themes
firstly supporting the local business
growth
secondly attracting new investment and
finally improving the skills base of
residents
the um theme to provide a set of liberal
objectives for the next three years that
reflect the council's current ambitions
the draft strategies appended to the
report and i am happy to take any
questions uh regarding the matter thank
are you any questions members
counselor mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman
i'm just gonna get my notes sorry marcus
there are a few um
first of all if i can draw everybody's
attention to page 6.2
5.1
the amount of 10 000 to improve place
promotion materials and branding
seems more than a tad steep to me
i would like to know what we're actually
spending that on
because my recommendation
would be
that we reduce that figure to 5000
which would then allow
for a further 5 000 to be invested into
the skills
training initiative so included in the
document
okay um
there is no mention of our neet
i know that we have
a low percentage
in relation to the rest of the uk
of not sorry neat is not in employment
education or training
but what plans are there for this cohort
how would the training needs be matched
to meet the local skills gap there's a
couple of questions there
page 6.7
there's obvious numbers missing
to the opening paragraph if we can have
those
um
and
i would also like to know
will uh reba mention within this
document and this is a recommendation
that ribbon encourages businesses to be
more responsible
and when i say that i mean um
social corporate social responsibility
many top employers have strong community
relationships through social value
policies
there is
also a lot of mention around the
objectives
and the aims within this paper but
there's no
clear
kpis if there could be some key
performance indicators so that is a
recommendation as well
did i make those recommendations clear
enough
yeah
thank you thank you very much chairman
thank you um
mr holton would you like to answer that
first and then i'll come on to your
counselor
yeah thank you um so the um
this sort of uh budget spending it is
only sort of indicative
um
and so we're happy to consider
tweaking that or changing as may come
along but it's their indicative budgets
but the 10k is also for um a video
promotion as well so it's making a video
of the sort of uh
um of the district
as a promotional piece so that's why
it's a little bit on the higher side
than perhaps um you'd expect to see
originally but there are
other reserves available anyway so if if
additional is required uh for addressing
training needs then i think we'd be able
to find that anyway
on that matter with with the neat um
we can mention that explicitly within
within there um there is obviously uh
mentioned training programs but i think
it's quite high level as a strategy so
we've not gone into just too much detail
but um certainly um we can flesh out in
a work program that can come back if you
require but we're trying to keep the
strategy fairly sort of slim so i didn't
want to go into too much detail at this
stage and with reba
um similar again um i think we probably
think there is the pledge and so a lot
of the things you mentioned about the
social corporate responsibilities within
that pledge um so again as reba is
launched you'll see some of that detail
fleshing out with it within the launch
but again it's quite high level this to
sort of tuck in there i think
and yeah the kpis yes we think we're
aware of that i think that's something
we want to bring back to the group um
it's going back to this um committee um
so to have a look at really um so we've
actually report back on on those and we
accept that there needs to be some kpis
attached to this strategy
thank you thank you
um if i can just come back on one point
um you mentioned around the media and
the filmmaking um
a possible other recommendation for
consideration would be that it is local
and possibly engaged with our schools i
believe both the senior schools the
sixth formers have very good media
groups within there
thank you
thank you council ahoy
thank you chairman um
just a couple of points i think um
council mcpherson did raise the kpis i
was going to raise because i'm keen on
kpis
first of all i just want to just say
that i'm very disappointed that there's
no
in the three
um
which i've now lost the three
they're here somewhere
within the growth of the three threads
there's no mention of carbon neutrality
by 2030. i know we're talking about that
as a council
but there is a consultation going to
happen in the
autumn i believe
um for the whole district about this and
i think
we've missed a
trick if you like by not
linking this growth strategy growth is a
little bit of odd as well in a finite
planet but growth strategy without
mentioning it
or linking it to um
carbon neutrality
um that's a comment i don't know how you
can deal with that at the moment because
it would mean rewriting this probably
and that might be going a bit too far
but i think it's a bit disappointing
there
um on some
specific
points
within the
actual task we're going to undertake one
is about
encouraging businesses to use um
well it says develop rockford local as
an online directory and town center
guide
is that within the one of these costs of
the ten thousands or the five thousands
or is that already been paid for i think
um that's been i think that may have
been started or not i'm not quite sure
so i'd like some clarity on that and i
i'm not sure why we
i don't know why we need to use rockford
local surely it would be better to
encourage businesses to use
google google business which is much
more powerful
it isn't a cost to us
and it would be much more effective to
bring people into the district because
people are interested it won't know
about
rockford local
um
i'll leave the business park let's talk
about the
final point i'm going to make is about
the
the um
high street conference
we've been i've met some console
consultants in the high street of radio
i couldn't do the other ones
um they seemed to come back with a
i think that was to bring back the high
street
i'm aware
of fremont market radicals have done
some good research
in rainey hockley
and rochard i understand rocha parish
council has taken up the free market
radical ideas and are running with those
i think
um i don't know if anyone's from really
town council but i think randy town
councilman have also are also looking at
this and bringing well yeah i think cats
are belted
um and i think they are they spoke about
that their last meeting and maybe bring
those in and i want to know why why we
aren't
using their data um
and is the information they've gained do
you expect it to be much different from
a high street conference or will you use
that to feed into the high street hyde
street
conference
that's it really okay
okay so um
i think i think the first one the green
economy i mean noted but like you say
it's it's it's more of an
observation than a recommendation this
stage yeah
the um rockford local
it's
i think something we're going to trial
but i i take your point the google
business you know is also an effective
medium so it's something to trial but
then reflect on sorry chairman come out
just come back on this i think
it's very important that
i've been here quite a long time and
sometimes sometimes i think council
mcpherson sorry
councilman will remember this and some
of the longest serving councils remember
this but we've been here before
and it failed before what why would you
think it'd be different um i can't
remember what it was called it was shop
at my local
and it was no different to this in my
view it was an online directory and it
never got particularly good
um hits or anything nothing and i just
wonder why we think
doing the same thing again will work
better this time
sometimes it does i mean i know i hate
to say that we've done it before yeah so
you can't write things off completely i
think there was one um there was um
requests to see that tried again i think
so when we get so it is part of the
funding it's already paid for
um so so that there is um
uh i guess let's see if it works this
time you know and if it does it does it
doesn't then i think if google business
is more effective then we will try that
in the future
can i just come back can we try both
well we'll
encourage both
yeah could that be a recommendation that
rather than just you rotford local that
we should also encourage i think we'd
look to usually have a plan to encourage
businesses to use google
business i think in the high levels ncaa
we would look to all mediums to try and
promote businesses within the district
so i think it should be in
um
it's the recommendation that we
encourage businesses to use google
business as well as watch with local
and i think on the last question i mean
yeah we will look at all sources of data
um going forward for the high street
conference they'll be foolish not to be
speaking to free market radicals yes we
will be here they are based in rochester
yes thank you
thank you council mrs gooding
i think uh councillor hoyas probably
picked me at the post there with the uh
the free market radicals as i was
just going to um
recommend new innovative providers as
opposed to the existing known people
within rochefort district council so
thank you for that
council raj um
and and the entrepreneurial and there
are other there are others that are
local that we could tap into
like you've already mentioned so leave
that with you
thank you
okay
okay
um
cancer mr newport
thank you
um i think we've already um
uh councillor has already mentioned kpis
and
one of the things that i'd be keen to um
to discuss and and to recommend is that
the analytics from
we need to have the analytics for this
rochford local
directory
how are we going to measure the success
of some of these schemes
i think it's very important to
understand how that's going to be
measured and at what point
is it deemed a success i mean
we've got
um you know you can launch a website
that's fine anyone can do that but
how much money is going to be poured
into it is it capped at 10 000 pounds i
mean what's the marketing budget behind
it is that included in the 10 000 or is
that just the development cost
it's all very well just putting it out
up there but if no one knows about it
it's not gonna get very far
um
i'm just
gonna come back to the pre-meeting notes
because um there's another question i
don't think it's been asked on here
just bear with me
um
yeah so one of the
one of the um
notes that we've got down here is
about item 3.3 the new strategy has been
designed to be a concise document which
can be used to underpin specific actions
i think council mason had asked
how will ordinary members be advised
when the smart objectives have been set
and what are they for
at each subset or work stream and to be
able to have
a performance report at that level over
the year
i think that was already i don't know if
that's already been put to the officer
um
one of the other um recommendations that
i'd like to put forward is that rdc
uh look at the partnership between
brentwood to look at the ideas
and the resources
that they have
and the skills that they've already been
using because i know their economic
um
strategy i suppose is more advanced than
us
in some respects so
that would be one of the recommendations
that i'd like to make
okay
mr holton would you like to comment on
any of those
i think the key one is around the
objectives i think without the kpis
they're not smart i said so i think the
kpis so you you've got the action plan
sort of the year ahead mapped out but i
think what that needs to be underpinned
by is those kpis so then you'll be able
to measure whether we've actually
achieved against those
but i think you probably said they do
need to be smart rather than just at the
moment they're aspirational so that that
does need to be sort of i said that
suite of kpi's i think we're the way to
do that
it's a recommendation um regarding the
um working with brentwood i think is a
given really but yes that's happy to
have that explicitly written in there
thank you oh thank you councilman mrs
belton i think you want to
say something thank you um in response
to that and a couple of other questions
if i may just cover them all off um the
carbon neutral element um i completely
agree but it's captured within reba so
reba is a part of the strategy and the
carbon neutral message will come fully
through the the reba incentive so i hope
that that will pick that up and
obviously gain momentum as it launches
um kpis absolutely i agree with um
councillor mcpherson it was one of the
first things i pointed out that these
these objectives have got to be
measurable if they're not measurable
they may as well not be there because we
don't know if we're succeeding in our
goals
and as
marcus has pointed out we feel the best
way to do that is actually come back to
this committee with a set of kpis to be
scrutinized essentially
um and they need to be measurable that's
really important and one of those would
be the neat figures because i think one
of our kpis should be that we reduce
that figure over the course of a year
there's no point investing in training
and skills and development and coaching
if it doesn't create any employment at
the end of it so
i think we we have the same
ideas as that it's just about getting
that on paper for a set of kpis
um regarding the high street conference
and the external data
it's it's very important that we bring
in all the data that's already been
captured over the past year two years
three years but also look to develop
really localized data as well we need to
be able to as a council reach out and
find ways to contact landlords of some
of the empty buildings for example
something that is notoriously difficult
to do so this is about encapsulating a
a broader set of data that we can use to
develop and and and really build on with
the economic strategy over the course of
the year
and everything else i think has been
covered thank you
thank you
council across
my
absence sharp a question that he wanted
to ask
in relation to page 6.7
and it mentions the port of creeksy
and also the thames freeport
his question relates to uh the perceived
one of the perceived
touted benefits of brexit uh being free
ports and uh could it be a consideration
or recommendation that we look at
the possibility of a free port um in
rochford i.e uh creeksy
obviously it would mean a big expansion
and potential
but the potential for employment um in
that free is is very significant
um a question of my own um which relates
to
item five uh sorry
the
councillor
mrs belton mentioned
reba
could the
could we consider
looking at
car parking charges in rayleigh as a
means of
encouraging shoppers
into raley
i believe
other towns in the local area
have
lesser
car parking charges i know this is
a difficult one but you have to find the
right balance between
getting the revenue in but by reducing
car parking charges it may be possible
to actually increase revenue
uh so will
that be a consideration going forward to
attract more people to raineytown center
thank you council cross um
do you want to talk about freeports
um
so i mean under the
it's trying to be too prescriptive in
what is a very sort of high level
strategy but um we have creating
economic opportunities um we sort of
mentioned sort of about
sort of um thames freeport lower terms
crossing airport business park i mean
certainly it is within that spirit that
it would uh if it's something that could
be done and i don't see why we shouldn't
be looking at that you know at this
stage you know but the feasibility that
you know in my head says that it'd be
very hard to achieve but equally be
wrong just to rule something out but but
i'll be i'd be reluctant to have that in
there as an absolute line so we're
looking at a something that is literally
a seed within this discussion but i
think it been but it sits within that
that sort of spirit of that area if that
makes sense um
in terms of the the the thorny question
of of car parking charges i mean we have
a car parking strategy that we've
recently um sort of um created um
certainly the the high streets
conference i suspect it'll be something
again that that we can touch on then but
i wouldn't want to be too scripted that
we'll we will look at doing a specific
thing to x y and z with instant abroad
strategy but certainly it's something
that could be picked up within the high
street conference i have a view that you
know it could be counter productive
having loan costs so
i think to have the thing that's two
scripts at this point what we're
aspiring to do is to create a higher
footfall within within high street i
think is what we're wanting to achieve
um the means of that i think is be is
beyond the the you know the high-level
approach of this this document this time
but i do take your point thank you
thank you
councillor eves
thank you chad um most of the
things i was going to point out have
been covered but there's one in
particular that i think
we do need to address um if i could go
back to 6.2 the resource implications
the bottom where we're looking at 10 000
pounds to improve place promotion
uh
materials and branding obviously
i could you could put that under the
classification
of beautification of the council
um if i was coming in from outside and
looking at ten thousand pounds being
spent on or allocated
for beautification of the council and
five thousand pounds being uh addressed
for um projects emerging throughout the
year my
view that i would go away with was it
would be that the council are actually
more interested in what they look like
than they are in business
um so i would suggest that
uh however it goes and i do take uh
marcus's explanation where we can get
money out of
various budgets to play around with
these but in this document here that we
do make the allowances for addressing
projects that are emerging throughout
the years and the skills training
initiatives
higher in value than to improve place
promotion materials and branding
thank you mr
i think if that gives the committee
comfort then i'm happy to say the
recommendation forward thank you okay
thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson
any recommendations other than um
just an observation really um my first
observation has been answered already
because when i first read this report
um not having seen one of these before
i'm not quite sure why but maybe it's
because i've only been on the council
for three years but
i thought this was very bland uh but
nathan explained that it's so high level
and that explains why um
with regards to uh
my question though is
i'm reassured to hear that this kpis are
going to come back to this committee for
us to to look at
what uh every plan that any company or
any organization has has to have set
review periods to see
whether it's working so the first first
point is what review periods are we
proposing to put in place for this and
the second question is is it
aspirational for the council are you
hoping to achieve all of these this
municipal year or what time scale are
you putting to them
so
in in terms of reporting i think we're
understanding it's reporting annually
on progress um and saying that that's a
written report for me coming back in
annually um and clearly obviously um
i'll be liaising with the portfolio
holder more regularly in that reporting
on sort of progress throughout the year
um in in terms of the um
the um there's an annual there's a
there's at the end a year's worth of
what we intend to achieve that's
realistically set out what the officer
can achieve
and the aims and the sort of uh so so
yeah objectives of 2020 2300 and 6.11
and sets out what we were doing to
achieve realistically um the
why
they are broad you know in terms of what
can be true but they are aspirational
but they are achievable as well so we're
not putting anything so there was um for
example um suggestions of
um
seed banks i think you know in terms of
which would be beyond um i believe the
resources we have available um so but we
have tailored this to what you feel is
the resource available this time
okay
okay
thank you
councillor foster
observations our vision for rochford
it makes a statement um
we have fantastic connections to key
employment markets in basildon
thorac and south on sea by both roads
and road
i disagree with that statement i don't
think we do have fantastic connections i
think we should maybe set a
vision to develop fantastic connections
rather than we have them
other points on um and i think
mr newport may have covered them
on the um
3.3
um which talks about specific action
plans
um i'd be interested to see a timetable
for development of those action plans
rather than just the span of the uh
okay
than just the span of the i understand
it's a strategic plan but the covering
note talks about developing the specific
action plans i'd just like to understand
the timetable okay
also
my final point is that
in the vision again on 6.6
it talks around the 8 000 new homes over
the next 20 years i'm not sure
that that's an agreed number in the
planning policy group which hasn't met
for some time
thank you okay thanks sorry councillor
belton i think you wanted to come in
just on on the previous point regarding
reporting back and communications i
would certainly wanting to be wanting to
be communicating with members much more
frequently i don't want to wait till the
end of the year to realize or to
feedback that something has or hasn't
worked so whilst the annual report the
official report may be annually i would
be wanting to set up a mechanism to
report back to the relevant people or
members as a whole much more frequently
than that because i think this is going
to be a fluid strategy and where things
are changing and developing and it's
important that we know and then learn
from any mistakes or take advantage of
things that are working well
okay thank you
i meant to mention in relation to the
point council cross made about reducing
car parking charges
sxcc as you know
have a policy to reduce use of cars and
encourage use of public transport
which would support the carbon neutral
approach encouraging car use by reducing
car parking prices actually might
increase our carbon output
yeah thank you mr hutton
thank you um so the um
i think you've touched on the reporting
background so the um action plans i
think we'd have to come back with a um
i'd have to speak to the officers
involved to actually come back some
proper date so that's i'd be reluctant
to to state now um what those dates
would be um in terms of like 8 000 homes
it is what the government says at this
time so i i take your point um it's not
a
uh it's not an enforced policy but it is
you know
you'd find that many documents that
there was it's it's a sign posting that
that is where
our targets are at this time doesn't
mean as a council will approve that but
it but it is what's planned if that
makes sense
um
um and the car parking charge i said
well a detail that we could probably
spend
the whole committee is discussing if we
wanted to but a lot for tonight i think
thank you
thank you council across
thank you chairman i was just going to
come back to councillor foster
and he has a very valid point about
reducing
carbon emissions and not encouraging
transport and encouraging public
transport very good point
maybe we could
offer free parking to
electric vehicles and potentially hybrid
vehicles as an incentive to encourage
people to uh or an added incentive to
encourage people to look at some
electric and hybrid vehicles
thank you german thank you
could i um if you indulge me i've got
got a point that um i would like to
recommend um and it wasn't my idea it
was councillor bob milne and
some of the stuff that council reeves
and council wilkinson have mentioned to
me previously
but we should be looking at innovative
ways to regenerate and grow our high
streets
and one of the suggestions was that we
look at the work that chelmsford city
council have undertaken and see whether
we can learn any lessons from them and
whether they are appropriate to be
applied within our district
i i think the short answer is yes i mean
we're always welcome to look at what
other other sort of authorities are
doing in terms of best practice so yes
okay
thank you
members are there any further questions
council mrs gadsden
i was just wondering
if the council has considered having a
graduate employment program of local
residents that go to university and then
taken on board and minted here locally
by our councillors and also as a way of
progression planning
thank you
i i suppose it's almost a wider question
than the economic strategy but um
certainly something happy to take away
and discuss
okay thank you there are no further
members indicating so
we've we have a number of
recommendations that came out
um
and
what i'd like
to do
is so yeah
sonya if you could read out
sorry sorry if you could read them out
and then if if it's your recommendation
can you just indicate that you're happy
that is your recommendation
so the first one i picked up was um the
the first bullet point at
5.1
um reducing the um the figure at that
first bullet point to um to five five
thousand pounds um
allowing five hundred five thousand
pounds then to be invested in uh into
skills
uh training training initiatives
um then we've got a recommendation
around um having uh having sort of smart
and measurable sort of objectives names
and and you know clear kpis which
uh around sort of measurability
um
somebody mentioned uh the video
promotion whether or not that should be
local and should should engage with
local schools i don't know if that's
something that you want to include as
one of the recommendations
um that's one that i put forward
chairman if we're looking
we're looking
to purchase
branding and
film production then let's do it locally
so a local business or ideally one of
our
skip
schools have got the skills to provide
that service
okay
just just to double check and just to
clarify can we make sure that's for all
of the promotional not just the video
because i completely agree with you um
councillor mcpherson we need to be
encouraging local business
okay so marketing and marketing and
promotion more generally that whole
section
then
i think there was a recommendation
around encouraging businesses to use go
google business as well as rockford
local yep
um
kpis we've already covered
um and a recommendation around rdc
looking at the partnership with uh with
brentwood borough council to look at the
skills and ideas that they have to see
whether
there are any transferable that we could
and i use
other than that there's another
recommendation around looking at
childhood city yes so uh so basically
the last one i've picked up is around uh
looking at innovative ways to uh to
regenerate the high straight and can we
learn any lessons from chelmsford city
council see if those can be applied to
our district thanks
thanks cancer eaves is indicating
for the figures that actually appear in
the report 6.2
on section 5.1
for the figures for the promotional
materials and branding for the council
to be reflected as being less than what
we are actually spending on
uh investment uh in training skills and
projects
so as i think we had agreement on that
um
is that can i just clarify is that the
one where counselor mrs mcpherson asked
about reducing
the promotion material by five
to five thousand pounds and using that
as tr using that extra money for
training
yes doesn't matter what the figure is
but i think the figure should be higher
for
uh
investment in skills training
initiatives and
projects so for instance
if we then reduced the um place
promotion etc to 5000 pounds as
councilman person has recommended then
those last two items that are down at 5
000 should be down as 10 000 each
yeah okay i think that's covered yeah i
think that's covered by so we've got
that okay members
sorry council foster
the comment about fantastic connections
which i think is incorrect i talked
about
developing infrastructure to create
fantastic connections
and
i don't want to put words into your
mouth but are you recommending that we
change that to say that we looked
okay welcome back members can you all
see the
screen or if you can turn around and see
the screen
once again this is a test of my uh
relatively new glasses but i can
actually see from here
and what we'll do is we'll go through
we've got three recommendations and what
we'll do is we'll take each a vote on
each recommendation
i'm sorry there's more below so each
recommendation i will read the
recommendation i will ask an indication
those who have for
the recommendation those against any
abstinent abstentions
so the first recommendation is that on
paragraph 5.1 of the report
that the 10 000 pound budget earmarked
to improve place promotion materials and
branding be decreased to five thousand
pounds
that the five thousand pound earmark to
invest in skills training and initiative
be increased
to ten thousand pound and that the
contingency be increased from five
thousand to give greater opportunity for
emerging projects to be taken forward
members could i please have a show of
hands of those that are in favor of this
recommendation
okay that's unanimous thank you members
the second recommendation
don't move it
the second recommendation is that there
should be clear smart measurable kpis
could i have a show of hands of those
that are in favor
thank you that's unanimous
third recommendation is that the
procurement of marketing and promotion
should be local and engage with local
schools and businesses where possible
and in accordance with the council's
financial and procurement rules
those members in favor please indicate
okay that's unanimous thank you members
the fourth recommendation to encourage
businesses to use google business as
well as rochford local those members in
favor please indicate
that's unanimous thanks members
the fifth recommendation is to work with
brentford borough council to develop
skills and capacity around the economic
development to deliver the strategy
those members in favor of the
recommendation please indicate
okay that's unanimous thank you
the sixth recommendation is that on page
6.7 of the report that the words
fantastic connections be replaced with
encourage the development of fantastic
connections
those in favor of the recommendation
please indicate
those against
those abstaining
okay
thank you that recommendation is
approved and the final recommendation
is to consider innovative ways to
regenerate the high street and in
particular whether we can learn any
lessons from another council for example
chelmsford city council which can be
applied in the district those in favor
of the recommendation
okay that's unanimous thank you members
so
members we've got two recommend
we've got two recommendations um to the
executive that set out in paragraph
8.1 on page 6.3
of the report
and
the the recommendation is that the draft
economic development strategy be
approved as set out in the appendix
with the recommendations made at this
meeting
those in favor of the recommendation so
that is the recommendations within the
report together with the recommendations
from this committee meeting now with
those in favor please indicate
okay that's unanimous thank you members
we now move on to agenda item seven
which is the key decision document
and
yeah
yeah of course sorry yep yep please feel
free
yes oh sorry yeah the second
recommendation well spotted um yeah
recommendation two on the report is that
the delegated authority be given to the
assistant director
place an environment in consultation
with a portfolio holder climate and
economy to make any necessary minor
amendments to the draft economic
development strategy in advance of
publication
is that agreed members agreed
okay thank you thank you councillor
wilkinson thank you
okay moving on to agenda item 7
which is the key decisions document and
what i'll do is i will go through
each
item and if any member wishes to comment
uh please raise your hand
so the first
key decision reference 14 stroke 21
is to do with the provision of internal
audit services
okay
okay no one's indicating thank you yeah
i know there is something else
he's
i was i just
wondered if we could find out why sorry
why the um
given the
the the current policies it were of
linking more closely with brentwood
while we're linking
on this instance more closely with
basildon
i don't know if that can be taken to the
yeah as
as i understand it
i think
yeah i understood that we already were
with with president
right okay
yeah we'll i'll take that away and i'll
get a report back to you on that
councillor thank you
members oh yeah yeah yeah i've been
saying yeah no sorry your point i will
answer your point but i'll comment
on this
okay
there's a report going to the pool
council on the 14th of june on this
right yeah okay
next one is key decision zero one stroke
two two which is the environmental
health service plan
anyone wishing to
make observation
okay no one's indicating thank you
022 which is the modern slavery act
any members wishing to comment or make a
note
okay no one is indicating thank you
0 32
is the suspension of parking charges on
saturdays before christmas
any members wish to
comment no no one is indicating 0 4
22 is the voluntary sector grant
allocation
any member wish to
make note or comment
okay no one's indicating
key decision 522
is to agree um an update on the asset
delivery program
anyone wish
cancer across
this doesn't look like a decision to me
to agree an update on the asset delivery
program
um
i mean we should expect updates
continuously surely it's not a decision
it's
that's my point it's not you know it's
not a decision it's an update
so it doesn't fit the the
definition given him on the first
page okay
i'll take that away
i understand i understand the point
you're making i'll i'll take that away
and get clarification on that
okay
cancer reeves
thank you chad i wonder if we could add
uh to the title of decision there to
agree an update on the asset delivery
program
including the current financial position
okay i'll make a note of that
as well thank you
nobody else is indicated thank you and
then 622
which is to approve an arrangement to
share staff with brentwood borough
council pursuant to section 113 of the
local government act 1972.
okay no one's indicated thank you
members
so we now move on to
agenda
item eight which is the work plan um
[Music]
so
we'll go through
the the work plan and what i'll do is if
members are happy i will add in some of
the points that we were right or that
have been raised by members for
inclusion in the work plan so on
the 6th of july meeting we've got the
treasury management annual review of
2021 2022
if possible i would encourage you to do
the the training that is coming up in
june now i know that councillor
wilkinson raised the point about um this
training is only being provided during
the day i've asked um sonia to look at
that the it's probably unlikely that
we'll be able to do this this june
training in the evening but it will be
recorded because it's been delivered by
zoom so it will it will be made
available
um we're looking at the one team
transformation program the strategic
partnership with brentford borough
council
and
then the litter strategy
and i think just to check with uh mr hot
and that is pretty scrutiny is it
okay thank you
um you'll see on the 6th of september
we're not
showing anything in the plan but i know
that at the pre-meeting there was
a cross-party
consensus that members wanted to have an
update on the adp program and i took an
action to set up a meeting with the
chief executive the leader and deputy
leader of the council and myself and
the vice chair
because it was uh we've had the bank
holiday i've not been able to set that
meeting up but we will and that will
then start to flesh out the the terms of
the um
the review the information we're looking
and i'll obviously consult with members
on that
okay
um 4th of october
is the regulation of the investigatory
powers act
ripper
councillor faye
um but also what we've sorry cancer yeah
yeah okay
and also
um
so that's to look at the annual review
of policy and usage
so i meant to say on in september
in september we'd also agreed that we
would look at the um
how the review of the former review
committee was working and
what i would like to do is is ask
someone other than myself and the vice
chair to lead that piece of work so it's
taking the report that came in
last year to look at
how we're doing and how we should
improve and to produce a short report to
to measure ourselves against that and it
wouldn't be right that the vice chair
and i do that because we've been marking
our own homework so
i'd look for a volunteer for that
council sorry
river one it
it's just some clarification to start
with
um because i understand ripper cascades
down to the parish council level and
town council level
and that they
have
people appointed under
ripper
for themselves to apply it
um
i've i've been aware that
a security company operating locally has
said that they do operate covertly which
you are and it's employed by a number of
parish councils
so my question is could that be looked
at within that review
yep i've made a note of that and i'll
take that with louisa moss and ask her
to include that yep thank you
um november we've not got anything in
first of december is the treasury
management
2022-23 mid-year review
um there's nothing in january
pennsylvania
february we've got the treasury
management strategy
and the annual investment strategy of
minimum reserve provision policy
the first of march we've got the
community safety partnership
and then
april next year we've got our annual
report um
and so what
what i would be looking for is for
um we've got some
key pieces of work that we'll be looking
at and i would like recommendations from
members for um this this work any extra
work that goes in
okay
so i'm not asking you to sign up now but
what i would say is we should be in line
with the report that came out we should
be making much better use of task and
finish groups
and what that means is that members will
need to get involved in leading
that work sorry there was one actually
sorry i'm looking at council wilkinson
who's frowning at me um
because we did agree um that you wanted
to look at um the policies around
enforcement and that you said you'd be
happy to lead that piece of work well i
uh i acknowledge your requests should we
say
nicely put and i think we were looking
to do that probably
[Music]
i remember right
we'll set a date in the plan but that is
definitely a piece of work that we'd be
looking to do and i think there was
another piece of work that was suggested
by council newport and we'll look to
schedule that in and it's good job that
mr hotten is still here is to look
around the whole of the
planning process so it's it's not the
legislative
aspects of it it's not the legal aspects
it's about how we operate our planning
process and one of the examples that was
given to me was things like distribution
of section 106 money that sort of thing
okay so that that slides a bit i haven't
got a volunteer for that but i'm sure
i'll be able to find one
okay thank you
so that's the work plan so we now move
on to um
item nine
which is the location of hms beagle
uh anchor at pegglesham and this was a
decision that was called in can i sorry
cancer
myers before we actually start
discussing it as because they appeared
in yesterday's echo the fact that we'd
already given the money to peggleton
council
and you've just pre-empted about what i
was about to say
thank you yeah um what i would say is
that
if you have seen the article in the echo
can i ask you to disregard it when we're
making any recommendation or decision
tonight we make our decision purely on
the discussions and the information that
is given to us within this committee
meeting so
if you have seen it please please
disregard it don't let it influence your
decision one way or the other
um
so what i would like to very quickly do
is to highlight
don't find the paper
yep
so um the reasons
for calling excuse me
so the reasons for calling this in were
that um the original funding that was
given for the beagle project was for
distributing um
to projects across the district and
there were members that were concerned
this was only going into one
particular project
the second reason was that the
well there are other options available
so for example perhaps given a grant and
is whether those have been considered
and subsequently um
it's
one of the concerns
and
that was raised by
a number of members was that the um
whether this anchor really is the anchor
from the beagle and is there some risk
in the future that it's shown that it
isn't the beagle's anchor and the
council is given um
is embarrassed by this so it's
reputational damage to the council so
i'd like to
hand over to
cancer fda council williams and
angela hutchings to
[Music]
present
thank you chairman
if i can take the questions as they were
in the order in which they were posed
um the
the original funding was of course um
for a district-wide um festival that was
planned specifically to commemorate the
200th anniversary of the launch of hms
beagle in 2020
the moment has
somewhat passed uh in that two years
have elapsed due to kobe where events
couldn't um take place
in conjunction with the then portfolio
holder councillor fd we explored
potential to try
um beagle commemoration and the uh
objects of this original project into
the israeli trinity fair but frankly the
timetable didn't work and therefore we
would be in a position where we were
looking at doing it in 2023
um on that basis and because the
motivation behind the project was
becoming ever more distant
it was suggested that we might consider
doing something to support the work of
pakishan parish council who had already
begun the anchor project themselves
so this is a project that the parish
council has incepted
they have used other grant funding and
also funding from their own coffers
and it was it means a suggestion by
which we could
use
some of the reserves the recommendation
mr chairman
says up to
to support the uh that project and to
essentially um conf finish off the the
beagle um project uh and the objectives
that it was that were originally set
um in relation to uh issues around
provenance um quite clearly it's very
difficult to uh in the absence of a
direct identifying mark to say that any
uh item that is 200 years old
is
directly linked to the ship
however the provenance that's cited in
the report comes from work done by
historic england who worked with us
originally in relation to the anc
project and at that point we were
looking to apply for funding from
historic england to support
pakistan parish
but that again through the intervention
of
the pandemic meant that that funding
application never took place
and the parish council decided to to
move ahead with its own um project so
the uh provenance so far as we are aware
is as set out in the report um and um
but in the absence of of any uh as a
absolute identifying mark we can never
say with any certainty
that it absolutely is so it is a nature
of the beast unfortunately chairman that
in terms of providence we only have what
we have
the whole project right from the the
start uh over provenance um i don't wish
to uh
um diss any of the work that has been
put into uh into this which has been
vast
but
i have to say on the recommendation that
is here
uh for spending
up to 14 just under 14 000 pounds
on
reciting an anchor that may or may not
be that from the beagle
seems extremely excessive
and i would suggest that there are far
far better
projects that this money could go to
to promote tourism in the area
um
it's it's unfortunate but uh the the
hard facts are
that um we don't have any proof of
provenance
even of the boat um that is supposedly
in the mud dock
as i've read certain historians reports
that have actually said that they think
it's actually
an oyster fleet festival a vessel
so i think that you know that there are
questions over the whole thing my
concern is exactly as the chair has
actually said is that
in future
that this may come back to bite the
council and be a little bit of an
embarrassment
so i i can't support this i'm sorry but
thank you chair
okay thank you any other members wish to
speak councillor newport
sorry oh sorry yeah
sorry if i can just come back thank you
chairman um councillor eves it's it's
not uh you're absolutely right there is
no um proof that the uh the ship is in
situ um and i've been very clear that
we've never claimed that it is um uh the
mud dock um uh designation by historic
england um back in 2020 acknowledged
that that
mud dock was the last known resting
place of the of the ship
and that is supported by documentary
records but whether it is still in the
israeli mud is a matter
that we can't uh quantify and it may or
may not be another
another ship but certainly the ship was
in in that place back in the 1800s
um
yeah it does seem a lot of money to uh
be up to allocating for for one um
grant if you like to a parish council so
um in a positive light i'd like to make
a recommendation that
okay well perhaps um the funding should
be capped at a certain
amount of money to be determined by by
the committee or portfolio holder could
suggest maybe
but i think some of the other money
could be well spent
um
perhaps ray the
museum
may um be able to set up some sort of a
beagle exhibition and
use that money towards something
positive
for other people in the district as it
would take
um people from rayleigh around an hour
and quarter to get there on a bus so i
don't think that would be
too attractive to travel all the way to
paglesham to learn about the beagle as
well so maybe we could distribute some
of the funding
across the district
so that's what i'd like to
make a recommendation
okay
thank you
today
councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um i agree um with
some of the contents from her counselor
in newport um however i would are on
something like perhaps a roadshow that
went around the schools to talk to
the pupils there around the beagle and
its impact on us
again concerns about this amount
so perhaps somebody could answer
has the parish council
had a figure already if this is now in
situ
um our officer from planning is here so
he can probably say
if it's gone through the planning
process obviously
any sort of
confirmation of that
and the costs relating to it
and perhaps if we know that that amount
that is the recommendation that we could
possibly put forward to contribute
towards that
so can you
so um
what exactly are you asking terms of
costs
sorry
my understanding is it's now in situ
yeah so it's gone through the planning
process
and it's now there
what was the cost to actually install
this
anchor
do we know that thank you
the work that has been done with the um
project to date is within the um
gift of pragelson parish council we've
not been part of the project at all so
any works have been undertaken to date
have been undertaken by the parish
council on their own effort so i
couldn't tell you um what has been done
and what has not been done and i can't
tell you um what has been spent
so we have a problem there chair um
right away where
there is the possibility that up to 13
755 and
um
pounds could be spent on this but we've
no idea of the cost we've already been
told the parish has received grant
funding unless i heard that wrong
so if we knew the cost and the paper
then came back to us
with that detail and asking for a
contribution we have something to work
on
thank you
um thank you
councilman first thank you chan through
you
the report makes it clear that the
there's a potential number of
suggestions for um the deployment of the
funds um and um the uh um which included
an interpretation board steel edging
support lighting signage and an
exhibition the sighting of the anchor
and
its um
placement is not with it it's not within
the list of things that's proposed to be
done um
it is um intended at this stage to which
is why it says chair that it's up to
13
775 pounds and 18 pence which is the
balance of the unspent budget um and
it's just a list of suggestions that the
portfolio holder
um may or may not agree to um to go
along with so um it remains uh up to to
this uh committee um chairman through
you to make any recommendations that it
thinks appropriate
okay thank you councillor myers
what were they actually going to do
anger is already where it's supposed to
be
um well as it says in the report
chairman um the suggestion was that the
money would be used to provide uh
security lighting um some decorative
edging around the plinth uh additional
signage and interpretation boards
um
it's uh it's less an issue
of uh theft and more an issue of um
security and vandalism but i take your
point
thank you
councillor constable
i think the um the question i was going
to ask has now been answered by angela
because my understanding was there was
more than just the anchor
there was
a walk around that area to end up with
there and paths and sight boards
because if you walk around that area
there's there's a lot there and i think
there was
further plans by the parish council
to
open up the whole area with other things
for people to see in that area so i
don't think from what i remember from
the report that it was just that one
item perhaps councillor fd could
enlighten us more on that yeah thank you
cancer ft
um
this was going to be part of tourism
heritage
so it's not just about the anchors about
encouraging people to go and be part of
the diving story
so
[Music]
hopefully
as far as we know where the boat ended
up and as far as we know this is the
anchor and people will go and see it
people can look at the sign balls you
have interpretation boards they would
also go and visit wallacey and look at
the
um
the app so we can see the boat
and everything else it can be a part of
the darwin story in paglesham which is
the other side of the district from
raleigh which would be quite nice
because we've got loads of heritage in
raleigh with the women on other bits and
pieces and it would just be nice to open
up the district
so it wasn't
it's more about encouraging people to be
part of that story
okay
okay thank you
councillor hawaii
thank you um
i'm
concerned about the open-endedness of
the money it's up to thirteen thousand
um
i know that i'm reading the detail here
of what they plan to do but there's no i
haven't seen any question i would
expect councillor fd has seen costings
of this or suggested costings hopefully
um
oh council williamson sorry
wrong department so that's the council
of williams if you've
if there are costings from paglesham
about how much they do need to spend so
that there's some we have there is an
accurate idea of how much money should
be spent um i'm minded at the moment to
to um
agree with councillor newport about
this may not be the and councilman but
first naturally about this may not be
the best way to spend all of the money
there there could be better ways to
spend a large chunk of it
um
and
so
my mind not to agree but i just wanted
some clarification around
the costings thank you so councillor
williams you were indicating yeah thank
you i don't have any idea of how much
they they've actually spent at the
moment and how much they plan on
spending
um i did go out there usa to look for
the young cow and i did find it and i
wasn't
i have to say i was less than impressed
with the way that this project has
has been taken forward
um
unfortunately what happened is that the
pandemic came along and has put a block
on a lot of things that were were to be
done or should have been done
um
as i said i i'm not happy with what i
saw yesterday and i would be more than
happy to
accept the recommendation of this this
committee and look at that further
and bring it come back to the committee
if necessary
okay
thank you council yeah
this is taken away by the portfolio
holder to look at again
and to come back with
either
ideas on
or to come back with uh
either
concrete
costings for it so we know what we are
spending
and other alternative uses for the money
which could be as councilman pearson
said a tour of the schools about the
history of the big law perhaps talking
to the rally town museum about holding
an exhibition
okay
do we have a second for that okay is
that a recommend why
it is a recommendation rather than
emotion
it's a recommendation but we have to
take a vote on that recommendation so
yeah so we've got the recommendation
okay so council reeves you were
indicating
um
his explanation of what the funds would
actually go to
it's not actually what is in the
recommendation that is in front of us
uh what we've got actually in front of
us is for the uh
the money to be available to fund
activities associated with the
relocation conservation and promotion of
the hms beagle anchor
that is very
precise
if there are other things that are
associated with the hms beagle then i
would suggest that we need to reword
that paragraph
um because if we're looking at walks and
if we're looking at storyboards etc
along the walk
walks etc um that that is not covered in
this recommendation here uh and
therefore would be um a little bit
difficult to justify the spending of the
yeah so then we should be money to the
motion which means that that report is
no longer
i don't think we're allowed motions i
think it is the recommendation and we'll
vote on that recommendation to go into
the report but yeah you've got a second
so my point was we should be talking to
the motion
recommendations
we do we will we will do presently
yeah
it needs to go back to the portfolio
holder because it was called in
from that yeah
yeah yeah
sorry cancer reeves though
yeah i was just saying that uh 1.2 in
the report i think that needs to be
rewritten
on the
evidence that we've just been given by
councillor fd as to what he thinks the
money is going to be spent on
because this this is very
precise
on what the money is going to be spent
on whereas what council refde has
suggested that it is
uh spent on is is not what is covered in
this paragraph
just to remind members that this is a
calling of a decision by the portfolio
holder so the
objective of the calling is to ask the
portfolio holder to reconsider his
decision and therefore a recommendation
that the portfolio holder do reconsider
that decision and the amount of funding
to be made available in the terms have
currently been described i.e that it
should be less than the sum set out in
the report and with the balance
redistributed to other projects within
the district is a sufficient
recommendation for the portfolio holder
to consider uh and uh take back uh when
making his uh review of that report so
there is no need to make any motion or
any change to any of the recommendations
it's simply asking the portfolio holder
to reconsider their decision
any other members wishing to speak
councillor foster
um in the report 3.7
it spells out some alternative usages as
angela hutchins mentioned earlier
and
i think we should be asking
the portfolio holders to come back with
some costings against those proposals
and we can make some specific decisions
it doesn't need to come back from that
we're just going to ask again
it doesn't need to come back all we're
going to be asking the portfolio holders
is to reconsider so members we've got
really three options um well i've got
three options to put to the first is
that if
you are happy with the
um decision as put forward originally by
the portfolio holder then we would we
would recommend that the decision stands
but i get the sense from the discussion
that's gone on that members are not
minded to do that so
the next option that we have
is to refer the matter back to the
executive
and confirm for the meeting record the
nature of our concerns
and it can also include a recommendation
to the executive
from this committee so
we've got sorry angela could you read
that recommendation again please yes
chair or i can project it if that would
help but the recommendation is that the
portfolio holder for communities and
health reconsidered the decision and the
amount of funding to be made available
to power pakishan parish council for the
anchor project should be less than the
thirteen thousand seven hundred and
fifty five pounds and eighteen pence
available with the balance redistributed
to other projects around the district
okay thank you council wilkinson
um hopefully council williams supposed
to answer this bearing in mind the fact
that there has been this echo article
which i haven't seen um and this
decision has already been taken
we don't include no no
no no
sorry what i was going to ask was i
assumed that the money's not being given
over
right
chairman through you um if a decision if
a key decision is called in then the
decision hat does not have effect until
such time as the calling is being
completed right so it's an inaccurate
report by the echo no no sorry i'm sorry
for mentioning the echo i was not trying
to muddy the waters the more interesting
the fact that the decision had been
taken so to make sure the money hadn't
gone but you've answered the question
thank you
okay thank you sorry so angela could you
just for the
final time could you read the
recommendation please
and then
i would look for
i will move it from here please
thank you chair so the recommendation
members is that the portfolio holder for
communities and health reconsider the
decision and the amount of funding to be
made available to paguson parish council
for the anchor project should be less
than the 13
755 pounds and 18 pence available with
the balance redistributed to other
projects around the district
okay thank you angela i will move that
from the chair do i have a secondary
cancer reeves thank you
can those members in favor of the
recommendation please indicate
okay that's unanimous thank you members
um that is the final agenda item
and so the meeting is closed at 21.08
thank you members